foreign
[Music]
showed off their culture and their
resolve at the United Nations on Monday
when for the first time ever the general
assembly acknowledged the nakba the
forcible displacement of 750 000
Palestinians in 1948 resulted in the
un's first and longest standing Refugee
crisis and one of its most intractable
conflicts historians took note of the
event I think it's symbolically
important that the United Nations mark
what became a tragedy for the
Palestinian people which was in part a
result of an action taken by the United
Nations
um there is still a narrative that's
pervasive in the American Media and in
American
politics whereby these things are are
somehow covered by Israel's security but
that margin is growing narrower and
narrower and on the international level
I think it's really it's really about to
disappear Israel called the event
anti-semitic and encouraged other
countries not to take part this biased
organization is distorting its own
history I'm working to ensure that
member states understand that attending
this despicable event means destroying
any chance of Peace by adopting the
Palestinian narrative calling the
establishment of the state of Israel a
disaster
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas
addressed the Gathering for an hour and
called out the United States and Britain
for continuing to protect Israel with
their veto power in the security Council
they took part in rendering our people
victims when they decided to establish
another entity in our historic Homeland
for their own Colonial goals and
objectives Israel would not have
continued its hostilities and aggression
without the support it receives from
these two countries to this day
Palestine
enjoy the rights of a member State here
at the United Nations and
essential resolutions were never
implemented one creating two states
Israel and Palestine side by side the
other establishing a right of return for
Palestinians to their Homeland
a boss said Israel's acceptance as a
member state was conditioned on those
two resolutions and should be revoked
Christian salumi Al Jazeera the United
Nations
[Applause]